[Music]
on this friday night pandemic
predictions of a dark winter ahead the
fears of a fifth wave omicron becoming
the dominant variant this virus keeps
stealing us the next card in the deck
and anxiety over another covid christmas
vaccine decision division you don't
think it hurts my heart that i can't go
no because you're making that choice
one family on two sides of the
immunization debate
struggling with long covet i also lost
my smell and taste again the mystery of
why some survivors are stuck being sick
and targeting quebec's religious symbols
law why critics say the feds need to
finally take action
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
tonight with a warning for canadians
planning to get together or travel
abroad over the winter holidays with the
situation around the omicron variant
changing rapidly the federal government
is urging people to be extremely prudent
if traveling overseas as it's risky and
travel rules could change quickly for
people staying home the advice is to
keep holiday gatherings small even if
you're vaccinated right now the delta
variant remains dominant in canada but
there's evidence of community spread of
omicron in some regions
some new modeling shows if it takes hold
case counts could explode in the weeks
to come
this is another bump on the road and we
still don't know enough about the
omicron variant except that it looks
like it's very transmissible keeping
private gatherings small
is actually quite important at this
point
michael couture has tonight's top story
on the new projections and what could be
in store for canada if precautions are
ignored
it is tough and um this virus keeps
stealing us the next card in the deck a
blunt admission from canada's top doctor
that she too is feeling the weight of a
nearly two-year pandemic
it came as health officials presented
new modeling of where the
epidemiological curve could go
if the omicron variant takes hold in
this country omicron is not yet
prevalent
in canada as has limited
community community transmission that is
going to change here's how it could
change right now more than 3 300 new
cases are being reported daily in canada
if omicron overtakes the delta variant
and transmission stays the same it's
predicted by mid-january we could see
over 26 000 new cases per day
ontario's top doctor
is worried as of yesterday 10 percent of
the samples
detected at public health ontario were
positive for omicron
and it's anticipated that we'll have a
significant rise in the coming weeks
and in the next month to increase
provincial protection ontario is ramping
up the rollout of booster shots starting
january 4th all adult ontarians will be
eligible for a booster as long as it's
been six months since their last dose
other provinces are doing the same but
age accessibility differs
with the threat of yet another wave on
the horizon epidemiologists point out we
are better positioned than the previous
four with more vaccines and more
knowledge which could save us from
further health restrictions or lockdowns
if we can use filtration ventilation
mask wearing
symptom checks to high effectiveness we
don't need to close things down quite
probably dr theresa tam agrees we have
more tools now but also says we have to
look even further ahead beyond christmas
and into march break and to keep in mind
that omicron likely won't be the last
variant we'll have to deal with
colleen
mike thank you
with the holidays just around the corner
public health officials are urging
canadians to think twice about hosting
or attending large parties jamie morocco
reports on what experts are recommending
and what you need to know if you're
planning to travel overseas
kovit hasn't stopped christmas at
toronto's distillery district but the
arrival of omicron is forcing revelers
like dario winch to rethink his holiday
trip the numbers were spiking like crazy
in germany and
i i mean i would say it's just the
reasonable decision to delay a smart
choice if you ask our health minister
who warn canadians of new stricter
travel measures in the coming weeks
things are happening very quickly
outside of canada and so if they think
of traveling that should be a serious
alarm bell a serious concern for them
domestic trips aren't as risky but
staying closer to home i think is
definitely the better
choice keeping gatherings intimate to
limit contacts as well as offering covet
19 self-assessments masking when
necessary and of course getting
vaccinated for catherine riefer ludlow a
mother of two who's also battling brain
cancer this is non-negotiable at
christmas dinner nobody's coming into
her house if they're not fully
vaccinated that's that's it there are
ways to sidestep the awkwardness of
gathering your guests medical
information you can make it a little
more merry by using a free festive evite
we can't wait to see you and enjoy the
season's glee but please show you and
yours have tested covid free or pick up
this toronto-made christmas sweater
complete with a qr code so hosts can
scan you for your vax pass know
what the vaccination status is of people
you're going to be around you might have
to modify how you do things at the
deputy chief public health officer's
home this holiday friends and family
might be a little chilly bring some
additional layers of clothing because i
plan to also use ventilation to the max
and have the windows open for a certain
period of time maybe on the hour to also
improve the circulation of hair so
that's a maybe a bit of a warning to my
family members who are coming over
celebrating with stipulations so we stay
healthy into a hopefully happier new
year jamie morocco global news toronto
nova scotia is reporting a spike in
covet 19 cases officials say an outbreak
at a university is largely to blame the
province says 55 of today's 123 new
cases are linked to saint francis xavier
university in anaganish there are now a
total of 114 cases connected to the
outbreak it's believed the virus spread
at recent graduation events a
high-profile toronto mpa is
self-isolating after a potential
covet-19 exposure at a gala sunday a
number of attendees including raptors
president masaya jiri have tested
positive
marcy ian the federal minister for women
and gender equality joined a jury at the
giants of africa event an organization
he created for youth basketball proof of
vaccination and masks were mandatory ian
has tested negative but she went into
isolation yesterday after the raptors
announced dugiri contracted the virus
turning to the recovery efforts underway
in british columbia after last month's
devastating flood disaster it is shaping
up to be the most costly weather event
in bc's history the insurance bureau of
canada estimates insured damage at 450
million dollars and overall costs are
expected to be much higher
many affected residents live in high
risk flood areas where insurance
coverage is not available
for comparison more than four billion
dollars was claimed after the
catastrophic fort mcmurray wildfires in
2016 but most homeowners had insurance
it remains canada's most costly insured
event
potato farmers in prince edward island
are getting financial help from the
province it comes nearly three weeks
after shipments to the u.s were
suspended after the discovery of potato
wart on two pei fields the program will
provide potato farmers with up to five
million dollars in fixed interest
working or capital loans the government
has also set up wage support for potato
exporters and trucking companies the
province expects the ban to extend into
the new year
canada is threatening new tariffs on u.s
exports if the u.s approves tax credits
for electric vehicles made in the states
in a letter to key members of the u.s
senate deputy prime minister christian
freeland and trade minister mary eng say
the build back better act contains
provisions that are discriminatory
towards canada canadian workers and our
auto industry they warn canada is
preparing a list of u.s products that
could face tariffs including the auto
sector if passed u.s car buyers could
get a tax credit of up to 12 500
ottawa wants canadian vehicles and
batteries to be eligible for the same
credit
quebec's premier is weighing in on a
growing controversy in his province a
popular grade three teacher was removed
from her classroom this week for wearing
a hijab a violation of bill 21. the law
passed by francois lugo's government
bans certain civil servants from wearing
religious symbols at work lagos says the
teacher should never have been hired in
the first place
it was
voted
democratically
by the national assembly
i think it's a reasonable law a balanced
law
some federal politicians are denouncing
quebec secularism law but as our chief
political correspondent david aiken
reports nobody seems prepared to do
anything about it
it was one of the big moments in the
federal election a debate question about
a quebec law bill 21
why the discriminatory laws it was the
first question of the night to the bloc
quebecois leader who was indignant
those laws are not about discrimination
they are about the values of quebec
other leaders then chasing voters in
quebec turned on the moderator but after
a quebec school board enforced bill 21
this week by removing a teacher from her
classroom for wearing a hijab federal
politicians were quick to denounce it
this type of this this type of uh
of discrimination isn't uh
reflective of this of the quebec society
i want i want to live in it was so
disappointing advocates say it's time
for federal politicians to act on those
impulses and defend the federal charter
of rights for all canadians that is what
we want to see happen
and what every single political party
should do is unite behind that behind
challenging the use of the
notwithstanding clause bill 21 has
already been upheld by a lower court in
quebec but that ruling is now being
appealed by civil liberty groups and
quebec school boards it'll be very
difficult because
it really needs to
be looked at in a higher court
not necessarily at the ground level
where we are right now the federal
government though remains on the
sideline saying only it is reserving the
right to intervene in the future any
federal action though will be stiffly
opposed by provincial powers
quebec has made the choice of
securism
and
i think it must be respected
francois lego is the clear favorite
right now to win office again in next
year's quebec provincial election and
he's sure to campaign on a platform of
defending quebecer's values values which
include enforcing a law which many
outside his province c is discriminatory
colleen david aiken in ottawa thanks
david
for the first time in nearly two months
people in iqaluit can drink the city's
tap water the government of nunavut
lifted the do not consume order today
more than 8 000 people haven't been able
to drink tap water since october 12th
the city's water supply became
contaminated by fuel there may be a
residual smell in the water but the
territory's health officer says the risk
of recontamination is low
a major defeat for the founder of
wikileaks coming up how julian assange
is another step closer to being
extradited to the u.s
more than 50 people are dead and dozens
more are injured after a truck crashed
in southern mexico most of the victims
are believed to be migrants from central
america and a warning some of these
images are disturbing witnesses say the
tractor-trailer was speeding when it
crashed into a steel pedestrian bridge
thursday evening it flipped over causing
the trailer to split open at least 160
people including children were inside
many were trying to reach the u.s
through mexico the driver fled the scene
according to local authorities who are
investigating the crash
in the u.k a court ruling could
potentially allow julian assange to be
extradited from britain to the united
states
lawyers for assange say they'll appeal
the decision which overturns a january
ruling that said the wikileaks founder
could be a suicide risk if he sent to
the u.s as redmond shannon reports the
decade-long saga is far from over
on every step of the process julian
assange has had vocal supporters in his
corner
to them he's an oppressed hero of the
free press holding the powerful to
account only the ruling class have their
way
and and it's a tight-knit that's all it
is but friday marked a significant
victory for the u.s potentially paving
the way for assange's extradition
of course
we are slightly disappointed it is very
very difficult to get a fair hearing
from a justice system in the united
kingdom in anything
which cuts across the perceived interest
of the security state the high court
here in london overturned a lower court
ruling that said assange may be a
suicide risk if sent to the u.s the
judge accepted new assurances from u.s
authorities that the wikileaks founder
would not face the harshest of detention
measures those promises include not
keeping assange in solitary confinement
in a maximum security prison allowing
him access to psychological treatment
and the right to be transferred home to
australia if convicted amnesty
international has analyzed these
assurances and have said that they are
inherently unreliable assange is facing
18 u.s charges related to the publishing
of diplomatic cables and classified
reports on the iraq and afghanistan wars
in 2012 he sought refuge in london's
ecuadorian embassy after facing sex
assault charges in sweden which he
denied the charges were later dropped
after prosecutors said too much time had
passed
after seven years in the embassy british
police literally dragged assange into
custody he remains in a london prison
his lawyers say they will appeal
friday's ruling to the uk supreme court
should they fail britain's interior
minister will make the final call on his
extradition redmond shannon global news
london
the two journalists who share this
year's nobel peace prize are calling for
better protection for independent
reporting
maria resa of the philippines and
dimitri muratov of russia received their
awards today during a pomp filled
ceremony in norway in his acceptance
speech muritov called journalists the
antidote against tyranny raisa used her
speech to attack social media platforms
our greatest need today
is to transform that hate and violence
the toxic sludge that's coursing through
our information ecosystem prioritized
by american internet companies that make
more money by spreading that hate
and triggering the worst in us
the two journalists received the award
for their separate fights for freedom of
expression in countries where reporters
have faced attacks harassment and death
division over vaccination ahead how
opposing views are threatening a
family's future
you're watching global national
while the majority of eligible canadians
are now fully vaccinated against covet
19 there are still some who refuse to
get the shot so what happens when those
two sides live under the same roof
jasmine pizano has the story of an
ontario family divided
[Applause]
noah callahan could always count on his
whole family to be there for his hockey
games
that is until his dad needed a covid19
vaccine to get into the arena it hurts
you that i don't go right yes like
didn't you hurt
yeah you don't think it hurts my heart
that i can't go
no because you're making that choice
paul is the outlier in his family the
only one who's against getting
vaccinated a decision he says is rooted
in his faith in god his blood is shed
all over me
so it's like my shield but these are the
times of these kids lives that you'll
never ever get back again
and you're missing it all
you're missing it all because you've
chosen
not
to get a vaccination the first principle
to
to maintaining relationships even if you
have a difference in viewpoint is to be
non-judgmental this family doctor says
the first step for families seeking to
find common ground is setting aside
uninterrupted time to talk everyone gets
five minutes to say what they're
thinking and then the conversation ends
and come back to the table maybe three
or four days later or a week later she
says giving people that space can create
more time to reflect on their decisions
it's just crazy that some people
won't want to get it i've told them
uh that it's easy
or to get it because we'll be able to do
everything again
like
what we did in a normal life
noah is 11 years old and wants to be
vaccinated but his doctor told him to
wait he was born with a heart defect and
the vaccine could make him vulnerable to
side effects his mom and sister are
fully dosed to protect themselves and
him if you can't do it for yourself do
it for your family do it for noah we at
the as the adult are his protector
and it's up to us to protect him the
callaghans have had conversations on
this for months but nothing's changed
you just got to respect other people's
choices if they want to come out of this
pandemic as a family acceptance may be
their way forward
jasmine pizano global news trenton
ontario
next the mysterious cobia condition that
has many canadians suffering long after
infection
nearly two years into the pandemic many
questions remain around long covid the
mysterious condition in which patients
don't seem to fully recover it's
afflicting a growing number of canadians
canada's health agency says about 60
percent of those diagnosed reported at
least one symptom more than three months
after the initial infection robin gill
has been following these cases and joins
us with more robin
researchers including the team at saint
paul's hospital in vancouver have been
busy trying to understand why some
patients are still sick long after they
beat the disease are there a lot of
people still long hauling katie mclean
is receiving treatment and she's part of
a research study at st paul's
she's been suffering from long covet for
more than a year we first met her in the
fall of 2020 and have been following her
journey at one point she thought she was
getting better then she had a major
setback so i got all my original
covid symptoms from my acute infection
back yeah i had shortness of breath
chest pains palpitations extreme fatigue
you know
crazy headaches dizziness
i also lost my smell and taste again i
thought i had covet again i really
since the start of the pandemic clinics
like this one are being opened all
around the world trying to help patients
and unravel why and who is still sick
the syndrome varies with around 100
symptoms reported as far as i'm
concerned we're no closer to really
understanding definitively what the
underlying cause of this syndrome is it
seems like the virus is like picking
random people to impact
and what is it about these random people
what do they have in common
i don't know yeah it's still a mystery
to us
to try and answer that question and find
out who was more likely to suffer from
long covid we spoke with leading experts
in the field and their research so far
is offering critical clues colleen
thanks robin to hear about the
groundbreaking work scientists are doing
in the field of long covid watch robin's
full story on the new reality tomorrow
night at 7 on global
and that is global national for this
friday i'm colleen christie tonight's
your canada is this skate around the
christmas tree in point claire quebec we
love seeing your festive photos please
keep sending them to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching robin will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]